well to start out obviously you know
you're involved with the Mel Brooks
project and he's had such a massive
influence on film and television
basically since the start of the medium
with Sid Caesar so I was curious for
each of you what was your introduction
to Mel Brooks like a film or a
television show mine was Spaceballs that
was the first movie that I remember
seeing uh in the theater uh that was Mel
Brooks film uh and it just it was as
astonishing to me as Star Wars was like
I just I I totally I was young but I
totally understood all of the gags I
laughed in all the right places and then
I went down a deep dive and I probably
watched this year of the world Blazing
Saddles and Young Frankenstein like 60
times to each we just had the VHS tapes
it would go nuts for me it was Blazing
Saddles I think I saw it for the first
time and I was like 11 or 12 and
um
I remember just kind of
yeah I was at a friend's house and her
dad just threw it on and I I didn't
really expect anything at all and was
kind of like what the hell is this it
kind of just like I was like
um and I you know also
um yeah I remember just being quite uh
Enchanted by that film at that age mine
is I'm gonna copy on uh with jazz mine
was uh Blazing Saddles as well my dad
had the cassette
I lived I traveled right down in the Air
Force and we traveled around a lot and
like his cassettes were his life or his
VHS excuse me were like his life like
that was his like his childhood was in
there his like high school years were in
there my parents had me really really
young so like that was something that
like he would sit around and watch all
the time and I remember like
similar to zazzy I was just like what in
the hell is happening why my father
laughing so hard at all like very
questionable things and why am I also
leaning in so much and like I just want
I I love I just want to do this and like
I love this and so uh Blazing Saddles
for me for sure so how did you guys get
involved with this was this were you
contacted was it something that you
expressed interest in because of sort of
Mel Brooks's influence on your work or
was it something different I was
contacted
um I
yeah I remember
I don't actually remember I was I was
contacted and
um was so excited I mean I I had met
Nick once before and like profusely uh
word vomited my adoration for big mouth
and I think I met him a couple of times
and did that every time
and so uh I I want to think that uh he
liked that and then gave me a call
um but uh yeah it was
um a happy sort of yeah reach out from
from Nick and Ike and I got a very
frantic call for Mike Barenholtz telling
me not asking me if I wanted to do it
but Tommy that I needed to do it because
apparently Mel Brooks uh asked for me
which I'm sure was set to everybody else
in the project yeah so it was like a
great way of gaslighting every one of us
into like doing it because we're all
apparently Mel Brooks is really up with
every movie that comes out intimately
um but it was I'm sure like these guys a
no-brainer the the fact that we get that
we're blessed enough to do a Mel Brooks
project in 2023 with a 96 year old
living legend who is as important to
film as Spielberg but in the comedy
space like that to me is it was just a
dream come true true yeah I remember
getting a call Nick called and uh and uh
I remember he just said hey so we're
doing history of the world and I was
like yep what do you need like it wasn't
even like he didn't even need to finish
what it was and I was already in there
like similar to what Josh said like it's
it's this it's crazy that we get to uh
have the opportunity to work with this
living legend who asked for all of us by
name and even referenced uh all the
characters of ours that he wrote
you know what I mean like they
definitely sell you Nick and Ike sell
you
um
I don't have time for your uh
but no we it was you know this was a
no-brainer for sure I know Jay and and
zazzy you two both got to work quite
closely with Nick because you got to
play Mary Magdalene and Jesus and you're
in one of the few sketches that sort of
stretches over a handful of episodes you
get to do that wonderful Beatles parody
so in terms of that those characters was
there sort of any room for improv
because you had a longer sort of screen
time or was it all sort of on the page
really I mean what's not improvised
um it was actually really nice because I
don't actually I don't think of myself
as a comedian at all I get very nervous
but I felt like I was like this is the
environment where I can just go for the
lowest common denominator joke and it
will be accepted and so it was so fun to
just sort of
I mean yeah we were improvising a lot
and it was very encouraged
um which and a very uh welcoming
audience I think I kept breaking
laughing all the time which made me feel
really good about myself
um so um
um yes
I would say that
tons
from not knowing was as he was gonna do
for
Yoko there's this in the script where it
was like Yoko streets or something like
that and I don't know what sound was
gonna come out of her mouth and I'll
never forget all of us we couldn't use
the tank there's no way that we could
have used that tape because every single
person broke when she made this like she
grabbed the mic and it's like just
swaying back and forth this guttural
like
absolutely amazing but they just
encouraged us to like just have fun with
these characters and you know I think
because that particular skit is based
obviously off of off of The Beatles dock
like it was this thing of like how far
can you push
playing with you know Jesus as linen and
Mary as Yoko like how far push those
things and play with that and so uh
there I don't know that a scripted word
made it in the show yeah yeah yeah I
think that was one definitely one of my
favorite bits and sort of connected to
that this might involve you through kind
of duking it out but you do all three do
British accents at some point so who do
you think sort of does the best out of
the three of you Josh Gad wow I I was
also going to say Josh Gad I I'm so
happy you guys beat me no I the truth is
is I'm terrible at British I I it was so
funny because I was like do you guys
really like would you want me to do this
for comedic effect or do you want the
audience to laugh at how bad I sound
doing it and they insisted that I did it
and I'm still not sure if the if they're
gonna laugh with me or at me so either
way I guess it's to win for the sketch
well one last question for you guys and
it's a little bit out there it's a
little bit silly but if you
if you historical time period
the world leaning or not which one would
you pick I'm obsessed with the Victorian
and Edwardian period I just I just
um moved into this place that has all
these very Victorian feelings and it's
like
so the energy I'm into so I would
aesthetically
aesthetically I would do that
out a lot of places we can really go but
um
you know but you know history is history
um I would I'd probably go to Rome I'd
probably uh see what it was like to be a
Caesar go to the Coliseum hang out you
know watch a watch a battle happen
I don't know nice walk around here walk
around in a robe and just stinky all the
time you know all of these sound
theoretically fun for about five minutes
five minutes and then they just sound
really complicated and dangerous I guess
I would uh the 90s I would probably
safely go to 1996. and just
yeah I think I would feel confident most
confident and comfortable maybe as far
back into the 80s
um and just sort of relive that again uh
otherwise the Italian Renaissance to me
would be a cool place to to to be just
kind of checking in on what good old
Michelangelo and and uh his his Ninja
Turtle pals are updated
that would be mine awesome well thank
you guys so much it was lovely to meet
you thank you thanks you too